melb throws an epic Spice Girls themed  party at her house  [Music]  Gary spice is back on Friday the 42 year  old singer shared pics dressing up with  her teenage niece Tilly in one photo Mel  B is seen rocking her original Spice  Girls get up from the 2012 Olympics  closing ceremony in London the skin  tight bodysuit still fit like a glove  from her last performance you kidding me  straight glam dressing you know  Hollywood and we are loving how her  niece pulled off her iconic look in the  group's wannabe music video Tilly also  shared a snap of the duo on Instagram  caption thank you for the best time  you're the best love you lots like jelly  tots for always gonna be Spice Girls  [Music]